when Caitlin Collins brings up Mike
Pence Mike Pence Trump's former Vice
President says Trump endangered my life
that day with what he did and what he
incited uh will you apologize and Trump
says Ah I don't really think I I didn't
he did some Pence did something wrong by
not holding up the certification of Joe
Biden but one person who was at the
Capitol that day as you know was your
vice president Mike
Mike who says that you endangered his
life on that day I don't think he was in
any danger Mr President do you feel that
you owe him an apology no because he did
something wrong he should have put the
votes back to the state legislatures and
I think we would have had a different
outcome I really did of course Mike
Pence did not have the authority or
ability or right or permission call
whatever you want he did not have the
ability to reject the election of Joe
Biden and to somehow try to stuff Trump
into the Oval Office for four more years